[Music]
now is this true you're obviously a very
beautiful woman you but you're you you
have I don't know if you tweeted about
it or you I saw you talk about you
talked about your feet you think you
have very special feet I don't think
they're special I just I think I I have
I'm kind of there's this cool thing
called Priscilla T which is the way that
we can move our fingers and our toes and
so a friend brought it to my attention a
few years ago and I've been practicing
spreading my toes and see how far I can
get them and I was able to clasp hands
but with my toes with a friend once wait
a minute you're saying that your feet
you can you can hold hands like this
with my toes you want to try yes okay
all right wait I don't know that I can
do this but okay this is weird
first of all I apologize you're gonna
see my natural skin tone and it's really
like adjust your television because I'm
the whitest thing in the world okay what
do I do
I don't know how to
okay where do you want me okay okay you
just wanted me yeah you can do whatever
you want this is the most amazing
[Applause]
was that was that was uh man that's what
I'm not gonna forget people are gonna
come over it's gonna be later like years
from now our toes touched
I think in some cultures you guys are
married now phone call for me okay we
have a clip here this thing I just think
we're gonna get ready to clip this
spectacular now this is a really sweet
story it's a really sweet story
it's a beautiful coming-of-age film they
don't really make anymore
and this clip is basically when our
characters get to know each other for
the first time I play a very quiet girl
and he's more of the he's like her is
manic he's like the cool kid he's very
popular kid and you're not and you come
together and it's it's and it's lovely
until it becomes unhealthy yeah as all
things do take a look at this question
is spectacular now who's like an
ex-boyfriend a just like really pissed
you off that you should suck
that's just like you eat it and if
they're just right have an extra what
you don't have a single you're 17 years
old you'll have an ex-boyfriend no yeah
absolutely guys are doing yeah I just
saw two guys looking to be like that
Eric wolf and Cody Dennis wait why don't
you think here I'm just what Amy you're
absolutely beautiful oh my god no
[Music]
[Applause]